good morning everybody
um
Pro Vice Chancellor thank you so much
for the kind introduction for the
invitation for an extraordinary week
um you guys have done the incredible and
before I start I want to give a big
thank you to uh Vice Chancellor Greer
and a huge congratulations for an
incredible couple days
as a former member of the U.S House of
Representatives I have some idea about
the challenges of coordinating the
desires
needs
hopes aspirations crazy thoughts of any
politician and folks it is not for the
faint of heart
by chance you decided to do that with by
my current count two current prime
ministers three former heads of state a
secretary of state a president a vice
president countless ambassadors Party
leaders members of parliament from
multiple countries region civil society
and in audience
Bravo and well done
[Applause]
I also want to take a quick second and
just thank all the incredible men and
women on your team who made it happen
Ryan Feeney got a shout out a little
while ago but I want to give him another
one he actually ran a dedicated hotline
to our consulate to help manage our
entire moving Parts which also is not
always for the faint of heart uh Ryan
God bless you godspeed I have been told
you have the rest of the week off
um
and the same goes to our incredible
Consul General Paul narain Paul your
team has been incredible
um you have run me ragged my friend
um and
um for those of you that I've been here
for about 10 days or so my wife and
family came in we all moved in with Paul
so for those of you that think you've
had a long week he gets to go home
to an entire another family with two
little kids running around and
destroying everything that the US
government put inside the consulate so
thank you and to Stephanie as well thank
you both
and one last Indulgence
um
don't let the grace of Jane Brady fool
any of you
she is tireless she is tenacious and she
is absolutely amazing
um Jane you and your team have been
incredible Partners to me as I try to
get my feet underneath me here
um
it has been a privilege to get to know
you to get to work with you and I am
incredibly excited about the work that
you and we can do together so thank you
a final note of gratitude
to the people of Northern Ireland
for the extraordinarily warm welcome
that you have extended to me and my
family this past week
Lauren and our kids have had an
incredible time with you
and you could not have been more
friendly
more gracious and more kind
and that started
after 10 pm last Tuesday night in the
rain
with the crowds that are lining the
street to meet President Biden
last Sunday at clonard Monastery an
extraordinary exhibition by The Choir
the students here at queens and the
entrepreneurs we visited a catalyst
the shopkeepers
we help support in Dairy and Londonderry
to the crew that made the biggest ice
cream sundaes my kids ever seen
and devoured after Crossing that rope
bridge in carico reeden we have had an
extraordinary visit
to all of you thank you
I've also kept us busy with one
remarkable Adventure after the next
I went on a boat
that has a take off button on the
steering wheel
that when you press it it literally
launches into the air and moves around
on a hydrofoil
we cruise around Belfast Harbor at a
smooth 30 knots
a place that was once this shipbuilding
center of the world
I walked through a factory floor at
Seagate in Darien Londonderry
trying in vain to understand how can it
fix a laser to something the size of an
atom
I still don't get it
but thankfully they do
and a third of all the computers in the
world have parts that come through a
Seagate Factory
nearly half of those come from that
factory
a few minutes later
I was walking across walls
that are over 400 years old
on my way to a Peace Bridge
I walked through an old bath house from
the 1700s
and there were two bathtubs in the lobby
I thought it was an interesting look for
a spa
I turned the corner
and I met an Oscar winner
I turned around
and I saw a young man wearing a virtual
reality headset
trying to stop Lionel Messi from scoring
yet another goal
well I think Messi probably got the best
of them
that young man was creating a video game
that helps get people up and keeps them
active to improve their health
there are a few places on this planet
with a connection between the past
in the present
is so tangible
and I can only imagine how complicated
and at times how difficult
that must be
but there is a difference
between being Guided by the past and
being held hostage by it
one can and should
be proud to recognize the achievements
that have been made
while seeing there's a journey
still ahead
not as a balance that Northern Ireland
navigates today
though it has never been easy
though you have sacrificed greatly
as Senator Mitchell said from this
podium
this week
we honor 25 years
of an agreement buy and for
the people of Northern Ireland
it's your agreement
it is your home
it is your future
it is your journey
but know that I
and so many others
are excited to come along with you
as you embark on this next chapter
many have remarked this past week that
there can be no Prosperity without peace
President Biden as you've all heard
agrees
and he believes in the people of
Northern Ireland
he asked me to assist in championing
your cause and your case and luckily for
me
it's a pretty easy case to make
there's over 230 American businesses
that now thrive in Northern Ireland
employ over 30 000 people
the United States is Northern Ireland's
largest source of market value
for foreign arrest investment
predominantly
and high value sectors
and over the last decade
political stability has drawn almost two
billion dollars in new investment from
the United States alone
today
Northern Ireland has one of the highest
concentrations of cyber security
employment in Europe because
it is a top investment location for U.S
firms in the field
they are here folks because you are here
the talent
the people
the community
the possibility
in the future
firms like City and Seagate could be
anywhere
they chose to be here
they chose Northern Ireland
they chose you
two of my primary responsibilities will
be trying to get those firms that are
already here to expand their footprint
and of course to make the case to the
next set of Global Partners about why
they should come here
perhaps not surprisingly
many executives are already aware of the
case for Northern Ireland
they know about the talent
they know about the ease of Transit
they know about the potential for Market
access
they also yes want Clarity and certainty
they want to have a good idea
of what might change
and how and when that might happen
the sooner they have answers to those
questions the better for a Northern
Ireland economy
but there also can be no prosperity
without peace
and there can be no peace
without prosperity
indeed it was in fact an Englishman who
inspired American revolutionaries to
codify that unalienable truth and our
Declaration of Independence
that each of us was endowed not only
with the right to life in Liberty
but the right to pursue our happiness
a radical notion still today perhaps
when you stop and actually think about
it
but locks framing that happiness meant
that each of us was entitled to a path
where our own basic needs would be met
in the 250 years since
America has wrestled mightily with that
responsibility
I'm incredibly proud of my country
but I am not blind to the places where
our promises have fallen short
for while we lead the world in
scientific discovery and innovation
we struggle to make good on that
commitment to protect the basic Dignity
of every person
who calls America home
my hometown of Boston
we like to call the Cradle of our
Revolution
is also mentioned as a Global Hub of
Technology Innovation and life sciences
and I think that's true we're proud of
it
but a friend also recently mentioned to
me her old bus route
should hop on the number one bus in
Harvard Square
pass towering bookstores sparkling
theaters
through the sprawling MIT campus over
the Charles River
speckled with sailboats
she'd cut across the Tony Brownstones of
the Back Bay and then now
gentrified both fronts of the South End
not 20 minutes later
the bus would come to a stop in front of
Boston Medical Center
and one of the poorest census tracts in
the tire United States
the streets were lined with a tents of
the unhoused
although struggling with opioid
addiction
moved up and down the sidewalks
attempting to ease their torment
folks
no country
no government no economy
has ever been able to ensure that the
benefits of capitalism
take hold in every corner of their
communities
even one that generates 23 trillion
dollars a year
yet that is also our Collective task
ahead
from my backyard to yours
to ensure that the benefits of
prosperity and growth touch every single
soul across this great place
from a vibrant City Center
past the falls in Shanghai
the River foil
and through every corner of County Down
to be deliberate
to be intentional
to be impactful
if there's a place on this planet that
is resilient
that is capable
that is clear-eyed and Scrappy enough to
take on this challenge it is the shores
we stand on today
because you all aren't afraid of the
hard stuff
you have wrestled
through hundreds of years of division
tribe and tradition
country and Creed
pain
hurt
and loss
and you are still here
you're building a Northern Ireland with
the Troubles of the past give way to the
triumphs of tomorrow
where children can read about history
and not relive it
children like Jack McBride from Donegal
who I met yesterday
right out back from this Hall
he shared with me a piece that he wrote
entitled GFA poem
it concludes
but some still argue till this day
if the agreement's truly sound
is it the beginning of a new era
just a Band-Aid that's bound
regardless of the criticisms
we can all agree
that the Good Friday agreement
was a step towards Harmony
so let's raise a pint of Guinness
to the Irish and the Brits
who put aside their differences
for a future
that uplifts
here's to the Future that you have
earned
a future the Jack and every child like
him deserves
I am so excited and grateful to be along
with you in this journey
and I cannot wait to see where we will
go
thank you so much